y llegamos a la revista de prensa en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez masdéu rosa
bienvenida feliz lunes para ti vamos a
comenzar con el país con lo que
estábamos avanzando en el sumario porque
cómo será el mundo rosa en 2060 el mapa
con nuestros posibles futuros climáticos
ese impactante no rosa lo que vamos a
ver buenos días y feliz lunes para ti
también raúl exacto vamos a empezar esta
semana con esta previsión de los
distintos mundos a que podríamos llegar
a evitar en las próximas décadas en
función de nuestra acción climática más
inmediata y tal y como señala josé
manuel gutiérrez uno de los científicos
que ha participado en la realización de
este estudio que lleva el país pues este
es un atlas de los a futuros mundos
posibles y lo que el interactivo que
lleva precisamente este periódico nos
permite uno de los fenómenos que
quisiéramos ver por ejemplo aquí hemos
seleccionado temperatura media anual
pero también se despliega la opción de
ver días seguidos de sequías
a cambio en las precipitaciones también
podemos seleccionar el período de tiempo
que queremos estudiar por ejemplo aquí
hay 1950 2060 y podemos ver qué tipo de
escenario queremos contemplar si
pesimista u optimista el pesimista sería
el que se daría si seguimos con el ritmo
de emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero actual entre otras cosas y
el optimista ese si se llevan a cabo las
mejores de las promesas que han
verbalizado los distintos líderes
mundiales si te parece vemos aquí en
esta región norte occidente de américa
del sur que en una escenario pesimista
de aquí a 2100 la temperatura media
hubiera y aumentaría 5 grados
centígrados respecto a
1950 raúl rosa muy impactante de
sustrato el mapa rojo por el aumento de
las temperaturas
vamos a ver si bueno puede seguir
habiendo vida y en qué condiciones
brawn y por ejemplo otra de las de los
datos que señala es que este escenario
y mista conllevaría que para 2060 en el
ártico la temperatura media aumentaría 8
grados centígrados también respecto a
este punto de 1950 web rosa vamos a ver
que sigue pasando en esta con 26 y que
por eso además estamos analizando todos
estos artículos vamos ahora a condenar
la legitimidad de la competencia
cuestionada por la exclusión de ciertos
grupos de debate clave este artículo lo
hizo nin a la cam eso es y como bueno
han señalado muchos expertos científicos
activistas la lucha contra el cambio
climático es una cuestión de justicia
territorial social y generacional y uno
uno de los impedimentos para esta
justicia es lo que señalan muchos
activistas y es las dificultades de
acceso que se han impuesto en esta cop
26 señalan sobre todo restricciones
ligadas con la con la pandemia no con la
pandemia global que ha hecho que muchos
miembros de la sociedad civil no hayan
podido participar de conversaciones que
consideran clave según distintos
activistas quedarse fuera
este tipo de debates tiene implicaciones
para millones de personas no para el
resto de la humanidad y uno de los
grupos que más excluidos se ha visto de
estas conversaciones de la cob 26 son
grupos indígenas y este artículo da un
dato muy relevante y es que la población
indígena representa el 6 por ciento de
la población global pero protege el 80
por ciento de la biodiversidad del
planeta para que nos hagamos una idea de
cómo afecta no todas las injusticias
climáticas sociales económicas hacia
esta población pues al resto de nosotros
también y una activista el enemy que es
la coordinadora de la región africana
para la corporate accountability señala
que en la plataforma virtual que ha
puesto en marcha el gobierno británico
es una pesadilla logística textualmente
dice la cope nunca ha sido creíble pero
este año es mucho peor el acceso ha sido
el limitado de tantas formas distintas
es horrible bueno veremos en todo caso
el balance final pues de esta cumbre
raúl y lo que está claro es que sólo el
tiempo nos acabará juzgando el tiempo lo
dirá todo vamos ahora con media parece
medio francés entrevista a vanessa acá
te dice abro comillas dejen de financiar
las energías fósiles este artículo y son
heilig art este esta es una entrevista a
raúl ya van están acá te exactamente
esta activista ugandesa que se dio a
conocer en cierto modo bueno su figura
se internacionalizó por un hecho
lamentable que no sé si recordarás de
fórum que sucedió en el forum de davos
en 2020 cuando ella se fotografió bueno
fue fotografiada por un fotógrafo de ap
the associated press de esta agencia de
prensa estadounidense junto a otras a
cuatro activistas climáticas entre ellas
grietas amber que sin embargo en la
versión editada de la fotografía a la
que se envió a los medios de
comunicación vanessa una cate estaba
recortada y no salía en la imagen ella
viralizó un vídeo denunciando este hecho
pero también en el libro que acaba de
sacar este año que se llama ecología sin
fronteras da una una explicación de este
hecho y dice es imposible no darse
cuenta
de cinco mujeres que posaron para la
fotografía y ahora la única negra y no
europea no no me eliminaron sólo a mí
sino a un continente entero y
básicamente lo que ella señala es que
bien si su inspiración fue grieta a
saber que el activismo en uganda es muy
distinto que en suecia no y que ella
pues ha liderado grandes huelgas por el
clima pero de una forma muy distinta
porque no se da el mismo derecho a la
manifestación ni tampoco derecho a la
huelga ni derecho a la educación en este
país áfrica rápidamente rosa cerramos
con el 'washington post' que la touch
este es una parte de este especial que
ha hecho el 'washington post' analizando
cientos de documentos y haciendo 230
entrevistas a personas implicadas en lo
que fue el asalto al capitolio y señala
entre distintas conclusiones que las
agencias de información las autoridades
la policía no hicieron caso a las
distintas alertas tanto de informantes
como de agentes que ya pues esperaban
que se pudiera dar un ataque violento de
este tipo de manix seguimos hablando de
este ataque al capitolio rosa muchísimas
gracias por toda la información en la
prensa internacional mañana más de
revista de prensa vamos ahora con
nuestro primer invitado el día
[Música]